this is the technical difficulties were
playing citation needed joining me today
he reads books you know it's Chris Joel
I'm not picked elector the bounciest man
on the internet Matt gray hello YouTube
and everybody's favorite Gary Brown Gary
Brannen all aboard the zip line to the
poop deck in front of me i drowning in
front of me i have an article from
Wikipedia and these folks can't see it
every fight we get right is a point and
a ding and the special price for
particular answers which is and today's
article is Sergeant reckless is my rank
in the Army sergeant major
sergeant reckless yeah you get a point
yeah successfully saying this is
something or someone in the military is
it someone called sergeant reckless
before we go too far someone is putting
it a little bit strongly is it dumb oh
but you're close force powering up all
those be honest that the horse is named
reckless why most have had the sergeant
got a field promotion point start of the
bottom I'm worth it's worth it held
official rank in the United States
military ID it order anyone K oh no a
lot of donkeys it was subordinate
private donkey private ass this although
I think about the privates in the
platoon must have been technically
outranked by the horse look at the horse
horse can't salute Kelly yeah can come
it also the other three
yes but can it do that with people like
it's like oh no no you know it have you
seen a horse try although I've thought
about you but most of the horses I've
seen have not been in the army
a spur most nerves ask the horses I've
seen have been civilians
yeah but you clearly use it to reduce
their glasses or something even if they
weren't in the arm
ooo monocle came out in the length of
the bridge of the glasses for a horse
yeah that's fine a monocle still gonna
fall out to monocles
alright they'll fall out but that's just
a universal exhibition of surprise
normal wins could be purple horse it's
an occupy job around cricket glass a
prescription windscreen birthing why
don't you have those no it's like I
don't I have a windscreen
I'm a human me like one Massey
bit of glass soaked advisor thing ya
know cuz it's been massively heavy
glasses real cannot talk all that for
the nineteen forties horse at horse in
the army yeah yes impractical because
the size of the glass for the modern man
of today there must be thin materials we
could use for already on it you make if
you make the glasses thin are the
refractive index has behind so they're
really heavy science i've he's asked
he's tried I've literally tried to order
extracts for thing blast my base just
kept falling forwards off my face
because they're just so heavy in moments
of surprise are already time cuz at
anybody to offer any Mon spread huh
yeah no originally a racehorse
sergeant reckless was purchased from a
Korean stable boy at the Seoul racetrack
uh who needed money to buy an artificial
leg for his sister sergeant reckless his
sister no no the stable boys history now
a horse an artificial light sorry I
tuned out hop is really good side like
it stuff is in us he's a lot of sensors
fine tight with you know modified I'm
gonna but it's got a white legs it's on
a girl it is it I'm gonna be a point
sergeant reckless was indeed a chestnut
horse uh with I'm quoting here ablaze
and three white stockings Whitehead
marking and three white legs but off two
points straight awhile as its default
while I was his sister is it yeah yeah a
blazer a wide white stripe down the
middle of ice that's do you think they
camouflage that before they go into
battle a be an obvious target Leone army
station they might as well be if you got
a big you know you're in a but it's a
nighttime battle sergeant reckless is in
the trench with you see what's going on
that's that's what made him reckless he
refused to camouflage it we've made a
presumption here folks
ah I'm lady horse there we go her date
of birth and parentage your unconfirmed
what was what was the reason you would
buy a army platoon the recoilless rifles
why would they buy a horse glue no
lucrative income via betting I bothered
by you by recoil as
rifle it is basically a rifle that fires
without recoil uh if you think like we
think small so this is basically a
shoulder-mounted rocket launcher was it
a bit like the Indy I we didn't they use
elephants as gun platforms I know it is
just a packhorse well I'm just very
source to pack the tubing the rock they
needed a horse with that was strong and
powerful you gun could travel long
distances at speed nine-month military
career right um in a single day made 51
solo trips to resupply frontline units
now go over there let's see I think that
may literally have been the order
it was here are some shells big train
thing slide on the back and out it goes
out and back how do they know this horse
was I'm trying to run away and just keep
getting caught and sent back in the
other direction
it's an equine shuttle bus uh echoing
cargo platform cargo lifter if you want
to go for that it's this the original
shipping container I don't like big dog
yeah yeah that robot Google is working
on oh yeah yeah they're moving yeah
Google bought Boston Dynamics cleared
out scary at all the the all the massive
autonomous robots you for military use
you know basically the electronic
descendants of Sergeant reckless yeah
Google owns are some dynamics around
like good yeah
delivering your Amazon packages soon
yeah yeah I love that was slightly Slyke
in Google I wonder if the lights are
gonna go out anything yeah that's a good
point we are in YouTube sounds Funes mr.
noodle oh I see Aman's it's just over a
big race but not is less or it could be
Terry Google and Sons are just when you
when you type in your search queries go
right okay better better get the replies
to that he straight over the card index
[ __ ]
yeah well that's out of a cat trapped in
a card index yeah it's fallen to see
yeah
which actually in YouTube's card index
quite big zjzj
paper kit now ranks it but yeah what if
you hold on hold on
hold on archivist question do you file
kitten under K or do you file on the cat
bracket kid not come a young if and here
we go technical if cats the collection I
think I think it would be a kitten would
be a series beneath it alright I'm gonna
ask that question if you were giving me
cat videos to find I probably would do
and probably buy buy buy that by
category so I think I probably would put
kitten underneath okay
depends how they originally came but it
was Terry Google and something yeah you
type in funny cat photo they'd have to
get the cat out on the camera out and
take the photo to send you that's true
that's Victorian Google for you yeah
they grab me over
send it on with the courier lad serves
it with a hand-cranked projector you
wanted a funny cat video sir Manik
daddy's the same sound I've taken
accidentally Brandi most amusing it the
horse was known for a few things for her
willingness to eat nearly anything
including include ammunition nearly
about $30 worth of something gun cotton
poker chips wait for to cash out about a
three for that day later also the first
horse in the Marine Corps known to have
participated in a certain type of
military operation formation skydiving I
mean I'd like to see that it's not
taking a military operation I've just
realized both military operations and
medical operations happen in theater and
you're right is it's not funny is I've
just realized from the same word for a
foul yeah I coming I can't give you a
point for it uh [ __ ] cuter yeah I don't
I don't is worth a biscuit I'm gonna be
what I don't this is looking for type of
military operation some kind of big big
thing you wouldn't expect a horse to be
involving USO show ocean landing yes
absolutely point in fact backing up
listen to yes so for amphibious landing
does open the front is a grizzled
looking horse with a cigar as well
noonish or so matter with you are live
forever was awarded first of all two
Purple Hearts which is the memory you
get for being wounded point absolutely
right
the Marines taught reckless battlefield
survival skills such as we're talking
nineteen fifties here negotiate spiky
things put in the way to slow down I
literally I'll give you a point about
how not to become entangled in barbed
wire hmm helicopter how would you teach
it you just got no I don't know I don't
know how he trained all the carrots
round round through and how to lie down
one under fire also if she heard
incoming she would run from bunker now
insult is it's nice that she well I
don't know how if a horse can fit in a
bunker but is it stuck in the dark with
these who's just put weight on the
concrete between either wedged borrow
legs go put it on its flat goggles and
radiation seat as well obviously they
should put webbing on the horse so as
its countering for the guy you saw him
dragged to say is over boys just follow
the horse I what I'm the first time that
the the recoilless rifle which basically
rocket launcher was was fired me did it
not properly not recoiling she was fired
backward about hundred yards ffs no not
at her Neera Neera
she run away did she spit out her gum
and got Carl that I bang pump all four
feet left the ground as you can't jump
in a thing for horse Wow
any dilly for horse good you can hear
the answer but you see you never told me
everything out what are you trying
traitorous pop paper bags behind her
something like that
Oh bang but by the end of the bag hold
up a flash card by the end
the mission she was used to it when
learning a new delivery route she would
only need someone to lead her a few
times then she would make the trips on
her yeah I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine
Amelia although it goes behind the girls
behind a bush waits there for an hour
throws everything off and comes about
like he's doing your paper around yeah
took it there was a standing order not
to ride her but during the Battle of
Vegas Hill ah what happened when
somebody did went to a casino with a man
on her back um there obviously someone
wrote hope what what might be have
travel through one say three casinos and
a Recife Don Roy show did they traverse
a river no anomic test site more
dangerous than that less dangerous than
that the enemy line up minefield yeah
well I've got a ton of horse between the
mine and me I'll be all right
yeah that just in my head so there's an
explosion it's just rider and horse no
digital girl take up when she was
surprised yeah yeah but anti-personnel
mine field or anti-tank mine field
doesn't say I didn't know there was much
of a difference no yeah pressure two
differences pressure anti-tank goes off
when you put our the many tons through
it and goes off immediately yeah
anti-personnel goes off on the much
lighter pressure but goes off after
you've passed by why blows up behind you
and gets every gets everyone in line so
my question to you is if you are
travelling fast enough on a racehorse or
do you get heroes never look back
explosions OH being the man in the enemy
trench seen someone riding a horse
through a minefield with a following
trail of explosions
drizzle combat-ready horse first rolls
through with a cigar in it imagine that
the girder enemy lines going and as the
horse comes up spitting out the cigar
I'm the chewing tobacco got got any more
the noise though
what what caused that oh I mean the
answer is still probably no no no end up
with chunks of [ __ ] yeah so let's be
honest it but I do like the law as we
call it now delicious delicious lasagna
yes but I do like the way that Gary's
writing the comic book yeah he's writing
the comic book character of it after
retiring from active service um there
was a campaign to get her back to the
United States to the country that she
now served I don't want to kind of guess
how that played out a bit like Saving
Private Ryan another crack squad for a
second
I'm nope sailed I sailed from Yokohama
hold on this fast served in the Pacific
yes fought at Seoul racetrack oh yeah I
thought Sarthe in my head he was in
Europe too apologizing horse with a time
thrower 1950s Korean War yeah um the
ship went through a typhoon all still
fine
horse probably drove the boat the entire
crew - yeah horse of the wheel we're
getting home
wait what was the first problem with
getting off in San Francisco seasickness
um acid vom Devery we're not enough game
puns on the ball the thing is yes you
could have a point that that did happen
but we don't problems when we when we
get scurvy horse nope Noren teen uh yeah
I'll give you a point for that customs
were fine but the Department of
Agriculture insisted for lab tests which
would make her late for the banquet
where she was to be guest of honor
two things one you're gonna argue with a
fully armed combat combat experienced
horse yes - I'm glad she's going to a
banquet with banku where she's the guest
and not the main course that's that's
true yes why did the Marines consider
that lab test a bit of an affront to her
honor she had to pee in a jar you know
you were a long kind of the right lines
it was a blood test but was it an STD
test point yeah right they're testing
for doreen
uh which is an egg whine STI did she
have it no she's been away a long time
it did happen a lot you know
uh no she made it to the Marine Corps
Birthday Ball uh in which she she rode
his rest
in a ball gap yeah what what does she
get to rise or to get that an even
bigger horse
uh no carousel no no I'll give you a
hint it was not held on the ground floor
here in a lick in a little hot sorry
this horse has been like in combat and
the most amazing thing is if but a horse
and a lift I which boat someone is on
the third floor has been drinking
heavily on lift doors open there's a
horse in a ball gown with medals
what's the bottle down but something
stronger um congratulations Chris you in
this week's show
hey uh you win a pigeon although you
just just one you'd have to collect it
from Trafalgar Square so I came on
Britain him his butterfly net with that
we say thank you to Chris Joel McCrea
Ango ranan I've been Tom Scott I will
see you next time he's got the beard
I've got the bulk
Wow
that's there's a lot of learning West -
in that it's I'm trying to jar - diagram
the center - yeah everywhere anywhere
you can pull out - change an Australian
bird no it's not um if he didn't win a
sporting event or invent some kind of
metalworking process then a bar quite
frankly I'm outta here